dominique la main je fais partie des
préposés dead à domicile qui sont en
première ligne pour soutenir les
personnes âgées qui vivent encore chez
elle on veut les maintenir à domicile le
plus longtemps possible le temps que ses
pensées possible donc évidemment on leur
pose les questions d'usagé à savoir
s'ils ont des symptômes et tout ça on
s'assure que les l'endroit est
sécuritaire pour nous elles rencontrent
pour la première fois une dame âgée de
66 ans dont alain boudreau confinement
oblige nous ne sommes pas entrés dans
l'appartement elle rend visite en
moyenne à 3 personnes par jour une
quinzaine par semaine à laval ils sont
135 préposés des soins à domicile à
desservir une population de 3000
personnes
mais depuis le coronavirus ils ne sont
plus que 15 la plupart ne travaillent
plus présentement ne dû mettre à pied
120 préposé à travers le québec ils sont
8700 préposé dead à domicile à desservir
une population de 100 milles 70 % des
usagers sont des femmes seules à faible
revenu qui ont plus de 70 ans
mais depuis le coronavirus 4000 préposé
ne travaille plus auprès de leur
clientèle âgée on a présentement une
armée de préposés à travers le québec
qui sont à domicile à attendre qu'il
soit appelé pour prêter main forte au
gouvernement pour nous c'est
relativement frustrant parce que ça fait
25 ans qu'on travaille à former nos
préposés
l'enfant a été mis au niveau des ch et
celle des du milieu hospitalier
mais pour le maintien à domicile on n'a
pas fait appel à nos à nos préposés ce
qu'on a fait lors c'est qu'on a diminué
certains services non essentiels par
exemple l'aide domestique
alors à part cela les services maintient
domicile sont maintenus évent être
maintenus ils sont cruciaux dominique
elle finissait tournée effet son compte
rendu à la coopérative
changement de literie après 25 jours de
confinement l' isolement peut être
dévastateur anxiété tellement élevés
qu'ils vont préférer se priver de
service alors qu'ils ont besoin de
services aussi élémentaires que les
emplettes et la coopérative maintient un
contact téléphonique pour s'assurer
qu'ils vont bien pour tout le monde je
suis stéphanois mais le gériatre ses
fans de mire s'intéresse à cette
approche communautaire depuis des années
il a créé la fondation âge pour
favoriser l'autonomie des aînés et leur
maintien à domicile
ça fait d'aller vers de l'art offrir là
ça change la vie
puis c'est pas vrai les sécher s'est
levé on peut juste faire les upi ce
biais et beaucoup de gériatres vont dans
le même sens le mieux c'est certain que
ce que la baisse c'est que la personne
puisse demeurer dans son milieu de vie
le plus longtemps possible à condition
évidemment que tous aient besoin qu'on
ait répondu à tous ces besoins il y a
peu de gériatres au québec pour encadrer
tous les aînés leur équipe de
professionnels de la santé et leurs
instruments de travail
nous sommes près de 90 gériatre au
québec pour une population de plus que
1.5 million de 65 ans et plus dominique
elle se sent très utile auprès de six
aînés et sont vraiment très
reconnaissant qu'on soit là pour leur
donner le coup mais dont ils ont besoin
pour rester à la maison
ça c'est la plus belle la plus belle
pays du monde l'on le fait vraiment avec
notre coeur